- Okay so, let us know in the
comments
which one of us should cheat
on our significant other,
then tune back in
to find out what happens.
We'll see you then
on Every Damn Day.
- Cut.
Okay, great job, guys.
Ryan, good work.
We'll cut around you.
So just a reminder, the office
luau is today at four.
- Can we bring someone?
- To our office day party?
- Yeah.
- Sure.
- This is going to be so fun.
- Stop, stop, your fingers are
so sticky from those popsicles.
- Oh, Hannah that's nice,
you brought your little brother.
- Don't be an (bleep) Ryan.
- It's chill. I'm going
to go take a piss.
- Wait, what did I say?
Is that not your little brother?
- Are you dumb?
Spencer is my boyfriend.
- He looks like a young
elf.
- No, he just seems young
because he's a series regular
on a Disney Channel show.
- He's Pop Collar Chaz.
Wait, he's like 14 though.
- On the show. Disney stars
are like, 22, probably.
- Maybe he's a clone.
I heard everybody is
getting cloned in Hollywood.
Cloning is hot right now.
- I read that.
- No, what a 14 year old
have enough money
to have his own driver?
- A 14 year old would 100%
have their own driver
because legally,
they can not drive.
- No, people just do everything
for him
because he's a celebrity.
- Or maybe he's incapable
of basic
tasks
because he's a child.
- You bought your own beer
because you can do that, right?
- I got it for free and it's not
a beer,
it's a Mike's Hard Lemonade.
- So, Spence, where do you live?
With friends? Parents?
- My mother lives with me.
- So, you live with your mom.
- Whoa, okay, someone's
a little jealous of me.
My mom lives with me,
she couldn't afford
her own place in the city
and I had already bought
a three bedroom condo in cash.
- Cash?
- Baby, it's so amazing
that you can do that.
- Okay, I'm sorry,
this is disgusting.
- Excuse me bro?
- No, I just meant,
you two together-
- Really, (bleep), you're going to body shame
my woman
right in front of me?
- Wait, what?
- Hannah's body has nothing
to do with this.
- Oh, it's her teeth then?
- What? No.
- Oh, because she farts
in her sleep?
It's not her fault.
She completely
lacks self control
when it comes to lactose.
Okay, she loves cottage cheese, (bleep), she loves it!
Come on you (bleep), hit me.
- Ah!
- Spencer, stop it!
- You're really going to side with this (bleep)
after he called you
disgusting?
- Get out.
- Pop Collar Chaz
doesn't need this.
- I just checked his
Wikipedia page, he's 34.
- Ugh. That is disgusting.